ya sabemos bastante sobre números
negativos y también sabemos bastante
sobre fracciones pueden imaginarse que
comenzaremos a ver juntos signos y
fracciones lo que quiero hacer en este
vídeo es asegurarme de que sabemos cómo
manipular los signos negativos que se
encuentran en fracciones por ejemplo si
yo tuviera la fracción
- un medio esto va a ser igual a menos 1
entre 2 y también va a ser igual a 1
entre menos 2 todas estas son iguales
también se me puede ocurrir algo como
menos 1 entre -2 y
de ver esto como una fracción podemos
verlo como menos uno que es / menos 2 y
ya sabemos que si dividimos negativo con
negativo tendremos un positivo así que
esto va a ser lo mismo que 1 / 2 1 medio
ahora veamos unos ejemplos para que
ocupemos esto un poco más veamos el
primer ejercicio cuáles de las
siguientes expresiones son equivalentes
a menos
entre menos 2 primero vamos a comprender
esta está tenemos un menos
entre 1 - 2 y vimos justo en el ejemplo
anterior que cuando tenemos un menos
algo entre otro menos algo negativo
entre negativo va a ser igual a positivo
los negativos digamos que se cancelan
entre sí entonces
esta opción esto de aquí es igual a
entre 2 positivo veamos cuáles opciones
coinciden aquí tenemos menos menos
entre 2 veamos esto es lo mismo que si
yo tomo este menos voy a cambiar de
color
esto sí voy a tener este menos
entre menos dos pero este menos es este
de aquí menos dos tenemos esta situación
de acá justamente esto va a ser igual a
negativo entre es negativo es positivo
entre 2 así que estas dos son iguales
éstas se aplican y esta de abajo pues
también de hecho es lo mismo sólo que
aquí en lugar de tener el menos arriba
como en este caso tenemos el menos aquí
abajo esto es lo mismo si tenemos este
menos de aquí podemos ponerlo como menos
entre -2 así como está aquí y tenemos lo
mismo que aquí arriba menos entre menos
es más igual
entre 2 por lo que esta opción también
aplica y no elijo esta porque pues ya
encontré de hecho dos opciones correctas
por lo que esto de ninguna de las
anteriores pues no se aplica veamos el
siguiente ejercicio cuáles de las
siguientes expresiones son equivalentes
a menos g / h elegí todas las opciones
correctas bueno tenemos aquí está menos
g / h no está muy complicado esto veamos
las opciones tenemos esta opción menos
menos g
entre menos h esto podría parecernos un
poco complejo sofisticado pero en
realidad no lo es tanto si tomamos en
cuenta que esto que tenemos aquí en este
recuadro ya lo vimos al inicio
como menos algo entre menos otro algo
menos entre menos se cancelan estos
negativos y nos queda positivo
así que esto que está acá nos queda esto
que está en el recuadro negativo /
negativo es positivo nos queda g / h y
aparte tenemos este signo negativo de
aquí afuera este pasa sin cambios lo
dejamos así menos que entre h
y efectivamente esto es igual a esto
esta opción si nos sirve esta siguiente
tenemos menos g entre menos h si
nosotros tomamos este signo negativo
podemos tomarlo como menos
entre este de aquí - h y tendríamos
negativo / negativo nuevamente esto nos
va a dar un número positivo y esto es
igual a g / h pero no es igual a menos g
/ h así que esta opción no nos sirve y
no elijo ninguna de las anteriores
porque ya encontré una opción que me
sirve veamos otro ejercicio cuáles de
las siguientes expresiones son
equivalentes a menos menos a entre 12
vamos entonces a tratar de simplificar
esto primero este menos lo puedo yo
poner de esta manera
- a /
este - lo pongo aquí abajo menos
12 - entre menos es más por lo que esto
es igual a entre 12 positivo ahora
veamos las opciones tenemos esta menos a
entre menos 12 este es el signo que
quiero mover este menos esto es lo mismo
que tener menos
esta de aquí entre menos 12
o incluso también esto puede ser igual a
tener a entre menos
-12 aquí los signos negativos que se
dividen negativo entre negativo es
positivo y aquí también negativo por
negativo es positivo así que todos estos
también son iguales
entre 2 que son las mismas equipo está
se aplica y esta es a entre menos 12
pues esto es igual a
este menos lo puedo poner así menos
entre 12 o también lo puedo poner como
menos a
entre dos pero todos siguen siendo
negativos no es igual a entre 12 este no
es bueno no pongo ninguna de las
anteriores porque al menos encontré una
y con esto terminamos estos ejercicios